NARRATOR: Portraits
have been used
as a symbol of power or
wealth as a historical record.
But they can also
do more than that.
This portrait shows
a weathered man
staring into the camera,
surrounded by what I can only
describe as junk.
It's a captivating
and deliberate shot
taken by a concerned
photographer
who believes art can
help change the world.
AARON DRAPER: Hi, my
name is Aaron Draper,
and I'm a professional
photographer.
And I'm a professor
of photography
at Chico State University.
NARRATOR: Aaron took this
photo in the summer of 2014
as part of his master's
thesis, a photography
project he calls "Underexposed".
AARON DRAPER: What I know about
this man is that he's homeless.
He's a former veteran.
He's been on the streets for
about four or five years.
The objects surrounding
this man are
some of the things that he's
collected from dumpsters,
things that he's traded for
and got from friends of his,
and things that
people have given him.
And he's selling
them on the corner
to people who were passing by.
NARRATOR: Aaron
chose to photograph
the homeless community because
he felt a special connection
to them, a connection he
wanted to share with others.
AARON DRAPER: I guess it started
with a love of literature,
and John Steinbeck really got
me involved with this project.
I really enjoy his writing,
"The Grapes of Wrath",
"Of Mice and Men".
And he always sort of took
a stance for the poor.
I grew up relatively poor.
Because of that, I've always
wondered about homelessness,
and who they are,
and how they survive.
I see a people that
are resourceful,
and that have
found a way to live
in the world where nobody
else would want to live,
and in a way that nobody
else would want to live.
I admire their
stories that I believe
that they wear on their faces.
The homeless walk
around with the lines
on their faces of everything
they've ever done.
And I believe that sometimes
their hard lives really
show in their faces, which, to
me, create beautiful portraits
of texture and shape and color.
I also always felt that
photographers have a duty
to use their art
to change policy,
to change people's ideas, and
to make people feel and think
differently.
NARRATOR: Aaron is
doing more than that.
Not only does he pay
them for their time.
He also tries to track them
down later to give them
a copy of their photo.
AARON DRAPER: I've been
able to find most of them,
and head back and find them
after I've printed their image.
And some of them I'm
still looking for.
I would hope to think
they get a glimpse of how
beautiful and amazing they
can look when lit correctly,
when somebody takes
the time to produce
a beautiful portrait of them.
NARRATOR: Check out
this story on why
America used these famous
photos as propaganda.
NARRATOR 2: They understood
the power of photography,
that the struggle
in these images
might create a new awareness.
Or as one FSA leader said,
introduce Americans to America.
NARRATOR: And please subscribe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]